hi there steve kaufman here
uh today i want to talk about
staying focused in our language learning
um
and it's particularly relevant right now
because i think
to some extent we're all concerned about
the coronavirus covet 19 pandemic
and
in our behavior we're doing things that
hopefully will
you know slow it down
but language learning is something that
we can do right now
uh i'm certainly sitting here with my
wife or sort of in palm springs more or
less you know isolated that we don't go
out much
um i will eventually go back to
vancouver but i didn't want to fly back
with all the uh you know people all
descending on the airports uh at the
same time
uh we have a small second-hand car which
we could we can drive back
uh depending on how things develop but
so meantime i'm here
so i am deriving great enjoyment from
learning my persian and arabic
and i noticed that you know it's very
important
when i'm say reading in arabic or
persian or listening to arabic or
persian that i don't sort of constantly
want to check the twitter feed to see
what is happening with the coronavirus
and stuff like this because there's
nothing i can do about it
we wash our hands we keep our distance
we do the things that we're told to do
and so then the rest of the time i enjoy
you know studying languages and so i
came across this term on
twitter called fomo fear of missing out
now typically that refers to fear of
missing out like other people are having
fun and i'm not having fun uh but
obviously if if you're engaged in
something like language learning which
is tremendously rewarding and where the
more effort we put in the better we get
then it's important to stay focused on
that
and i find the more i focus the more i
stay focused on you know whatever it is
i'm reading or listening to
the more i'm able to stay with it and
enjoy it so i think we just have to
resist the temptation to sort of dash
off and do something else we kind of
have to stay with what we're doing
and and then i also sort of thought
about
how much of a of an international
cooperative venture
language learning has become
so in the case of my persian
i have a collaborator in iran sahra who
not only is creating
stories where she talks about herself
and has other friends talking about
themselves and we call this the iranians
and then she has created circling
questions for each of these little
episodes and they're proving quite
popular for people on link who are
learning uh persian but also she
obtained permission from
a persian
podcaster
who goes into
mostly english language self-help books
and provides a synopsis of them in
persian and
sahara is going in and divide them into
five six minute segments and then
creating circling questions for each
segment so there i have a collaborator
in iran who is helping me learn persian
i have a similar connection with an arab
speak arabic speaker in
morocco who is doing the same for
arabic podcasts
dividing them into shorter segments
creating these circular questions by the
way i touch my nose i've got to stop
doing that
uh
so and of course on my youtube channel
uh you'll soon see that i'm having
conversations with people in germany and
spain in
japan and so there's this global effort
and of course there's any number of
people online creating content creating
learning systems
uh creating youtube content in different
languages so it's really quite an
international
community where we are connecting not
only to learn languages but we're
learning about each other and so the
world continues to get smaller now some
people may look at the current um you
know kobit 19 pandemic as an example of
the sort of
negative side of globalization
and there will undoubtedly be
adjustments in terms of how much people
fly and in terms of supply chains and so
forth
but
we remain global globalized we will
continue to be connected it might be
more remote work more virtual connection
more online learning but we will remain
very very connected
and this is a good thing and
you know the fact that the covet 19
emanated from wuhan china
uh
there have always been pandemics from
the black plague in europe uh you know
spanish flu which by the way didn't
originate in spain
it was first reported on in spain but it
originated people are uncertain as to
whether it was in europe or in kansas or
in north china where this thing
originated and
h1n1 and all these others have
originated in different places so we are
always vulnerable to pandemics
what i think is unique this time is the
degree to which the world is coming
together the resources are being put
into you know there was a
a four-hour testing system developed in
singapore another four-hour testing
system in by a company in switzerland
um
you know i i saw that at the university
university of saskatchewan in canada
which is relatively small they're
developing a vaccine i saw there was a
bit of a news report that a company in
germany is developing a vaccine and
there was an effort by
u.s interests to buy that and take it
back to the u.s so that it would only be
for the
benefit of of
the us i i i don't i haven't seen that
story verified although it was reported
in some fairly reputable newspapers
we'll see if that's true or not if that
is true that course goes against the
whole spirit
of sharing of information sharing of
research information sharing of
experience so that
this threat which is a global threat
can be
you know mitigated in in a global way
and i think we will get the vaccine and
we'll get
you know home testing kits and we'll get
uh
you know perhaps some drugs that can
mitigate the effects of the disease will
get them quicker than ever because
people are so connected and of course
computing power and all this stuff now
i have to admit that i am by nature an
optimist
and in that regard one of the
episodes in the b-plus podcast
is a synopsis by ali of a book written
by a swede whose name i can't remember
was it hans rusling i'm not sure
and it's called factfulness and he
points out how
people tend to interpret facts or with a
lack of facts always assume that the
situation is worse than it is and he has
a number of examples i haven't come to
them yet because i've only started into
this podcast and of course it's in
persian so i'm progressing somewhat
slowly although i take it with me when i
run and then i come back and i read it
again
but
you know the
current pandemic
which will undoubtedly create a lot of
hardship death
suffering
we have to remember that the vast
majority of people will not have serious
symptoms although a lot of people will
so there will be a tremendous burden on
our hospitals and
it's conceivable that hundreds of
thousands of people will die or more we
don't know we don't know
uh however
you know every year if i look at
statistics from the united states
millions of people die of cancer
uh forty thousand or so i'm roughly
going from memory here but forty
thousand people die
uh from automobile accidents uh
four million people are hospitalized for
automobile accidents not that that's a
good thing and not that not that that
makes this suffering
worse or excuse me it makes it the
suffering less of these people nor does
it mean that we don't have to do
everything possible to increase you know
intensive care unit beds and
ventilators and all of this other stuff
but it is in
the
the pandemic is adding to these other
uh you know the heroin overdoses or
suicides which are 17 or 20 000 people
uh in the us and i'm not picking on the
us it just so happens that those
statistics are readily available when
you google so it's a
net edition of a significant significant
number of people who will die but it
still needs to be looked in looked at in
the context of
yeah
we do face risk
in our lives
and but
i think this
global cooperation in finding solutions
to cancer solutions to other diseases
that afflict us
that this is a very positive sign so the
kind of
small scale cooperation that we're
seeing in the sort of language learning
community is being replicated in many
other fields including medicine
so the current pandemic is a bit of a
gut punch no doubt and it'll have
significant uh economic consequences but
in the longer term i think that this
increasing
international cooperation
globalization perhaps with less flying
with less face-to-face
uh
is a good thing and i think we will come
out of this stronger with a new uh
new way of operating a globalized
economy
and so uh
you know i can't influence these things
uh i can follow them but i don't want to
follow them too much
because i want to stay focused
on my language learning and i recommend
that you do the same
uh
don't have fomo fear of missing out
and make sure that you wash your hands
for a good 20 seconds which is longer
than you think
and there's all kinds of videos on uh
the internet showing you how to wash
your hands
and stay away from people you don't know
and crowds and that kind of thing
and uh i think the best thing is i mean
i operate on the assumption that i have
uh
covered nike and i don't want to spread
it to other people therefore
i don't touch anyone i don't shake hands
i stay away from other people
and
we will see how these things evolve but
i don't see that uh
there is going to be a dramatic
short-term improvement
and therefore we have to you know
continue to do everything we can to
mitigate the spread in order to uh you
know prevent the worst possible outcome
for vulnerable people and therefore
you know undue strains on our hospital
systems in different countries
so i just wanted to share that with you
thank you bye for now